c'est à la tombée de la nuit que keziah
jones s'est produit samedi soir celui
qui se réclame du blue funk contraction
du blues et du funk aura joué ses plus
grands titres et notamment en guise à
mèze love tout ça à deux mois de la
sortie de son nouvel album
il
nous l'avions rencontrée quelques heures
avant son concert à son hôtel sa
nouvelle production nigerian wood et
l'enregistrer dans le studio créé par
jimi hendrix à new york un album plein
d'émotions dit il qui est le deuxième
volet d'une trilogie débutée en 2003
avec black orpheus spécialement au
nigeria mais plutôt de la musique dans
tout de la façon dont la culture
africaine est devenue de plus en plus
importante dans la mode la musique
occitane et de l'apport enfin qui est un
peu de trop un côté moderne de laquelle
à leur afrique
keziah jones dit adorer le public
français c'est d'ailleurs dans le métro
parisien qu'il s'est fait remarquer au
début des années 1990 et ce public le
lui rend bien plus besoin de prouver son
succès auprès des tourangeaux ce sens
d'histoire jamais bu jamais jazz
j'aimais faire la pâte également parce
que falla c'est le premier africain
musique moderne et son attitude ses
attitudes c'est très important et pour
moi c'est une grande influence parce que
je crois que après l'amour il faut que
les afghans réinventer la musique
africains parce qu'il fallait faire
avant il faut qu'on réinvente et la
musique avec un excellent chose que je
vais faire maintenant
fellah cet artiste nigérian qui aura
marqué la vie politique et morale de ce
pays
années 70 80 par ses attaques contre la
corruption des élites ne figure donc
pour qu'ils y aient jones qui a 40 ans
gardent encore une énergie
époustouflante